[Music]
news tonight on Carrie Fisher and Debbie
Reynolds we have learned that a private
memorial will be held for Carrie on
Thursday and Debbie's memorial will be
Friday now only family and very close
friends will attend both ladies were on
everyone's mind last night at the Palm
Springs International Film Festival she
was one of the most fascinating and
creative brains I've ever come across
and certainly a wit for the ages
Tom worked with Carrie in 1989's the
burbs annette bening had a small role in
postcards from the edge that's when I
met Carrie she was a great talent
[Music]
it was Kerry's mom Debbie that had
inspired the cast of lalala she was an
inspiration to us every day we watched
singing in the rain every day for
inspiration missing from the Palm
Springs festivities was Ryan's co-star
Emma Stone with strep throat she sucked
unfortunately we got a photo from the
emergency room very bad case bringing a
special guest was presenter Laura Dern
as our Mary Hart who both hosted and
interviewed for us backstage found out
do I understand you have a daughter here
tonight Laura where is she
hey kiddo I'm Mary what do you think
about all of this I think it's really
cool it's nice to be here pretty cool
[Music]
guy Oh wasn't the only one thrilled to
be there after all Palm Springs is often
a precursor to Oscar gold I think
but before awards season kicked off
Casey Affleck had to take a ski trip
with brother Ben we were trying to ski
ours and then decided we didn't want
someone to die we'd probably start to
take it easy also taking it easy natalie
portman expecting her second child early
this year thank you Natalie was in
full-length Navy Dior honoree ruth negga
wore a semi-sheer Valentino I just want
to know how many of you are wearing the
same thing you wore on New Year's Eve
the floral embroidery on Amy's dress had
a special purpose holiday sitting so you
know you start with dessert
as for her gown for Sunday's Golden
Globes he's not ready no actually I
haven't
so so that should be a fun Friday I'm
trying to figure out what I'm wearing
[Music]
you